well through the conventional
biodiversity we aim to try and
significantly reduce the rate of
biodiversity loss by 2010 and last year
was the International Year by
diversities was a big international
effort to try and promote biodiversity
conservation to reduce biodiversity loss
and the goal from 2002 2010 was to
significantly reduce rate biodiversity
loss and pretty much everywhere in the
world we fail to do that we've
identified by 20 different habitats
Titan UK and there's about 200 different
species where their specific actions to
conserve these different species and the
government was interested to find out
how much people willing to pay for those
species and within the valuation
framework what you have to do is look at
different scenarios so rather into a
costanza valuing nature and UK what
we're trying to do is look at the value
of that policy instrument and we had two
scenarios of the value of current
biodiversity action plan so what the
current benefits were entertaining from
a current policy compared to a
counterfactual where if a government
stopped funding by diversity policy and
biodiversity declined so it was looking
at what's the benefit from what's
happening and secondly what would be
extra benefits if by diversity action
plan was fully implemented to achieve
all the targets so currently we're not
quite meeting all the targets and they
could spend more money to achieve those
benefits currently the most important
services climate regulation and water
regulation so these are the types of
services that the policy deliver that
are most important to people in UK and
simply we look at the fulham of the
patient the extra benefits again we see
that those are important as well as
charismatic species whereas things like
wild food and non-food products people
don't really care about it which is kind
of to be expected to a large extent so
you can see what services different
people value
and finally we can look at how different
habitats have different values so things
like blanket bugs which store carbon and
regulate water on a per hectare pieces
they deliver hice lose line 30 current
services and right there's a enhance
services so blanket bugs I purple
mewling grass which is like Heather I
course the floodplains and native
woodlands are the habitat tights it
deliver most services per hectare and we
can get that information and I could
split this up almost into different
ecosystem services I think if you
disaggregate the data that much you
start inducing lots of errors so I think
what we've demonstrated in this research
is that different habitats are important
delivered different services and through
the conservation policies is we're
actually get involved you for money for
delivery those services oh and you seem
that again so I think the time's up so
just to summarize the day generally
speaking economic markets have failed to
deliver environmental goods there's no
market price for them and so but people
still gain benefits from it and what
we's environmental economists have had
to think about novel ways in which we
can capture of those values either
through revealed preference techniques
travel costs or stated preference choice
experiments